[Music]
these are the monster footage of the
trailers of the Monarch series that will
be seen in Apple TV Plus in a couple of
weeks we have arranged them in
accordance to their timeline and
sequence of events there are just a few
of them as of the trailers but I can
assure you that there will be more
monsters that will be seen when the show
airs let's get to it year
1952 location unknown abandoned Factory
site species swarm insectoids size small
[Music]
cm yeah
1952 location Philippines unknown
Battleship draag Inland species black
women like super
species size large 200 ft or 60 M
long year
1954 location bikini ATO Pacific Ocean
species titanis GUI
size gigantic 355 ft
tall year
1973 location Skull Island Pacific Ocean
species trapdor crab and mother long
legs size medium 20 to 25 ft
[Music]
tall year
2014 location San Francisco United
States species tal goira size gigantic
355 ft
tall
year
2014 location northern Alaska United
States species Subterranean Maman mold
Titan size large 60 ft 18 M
[Music]
tall
year 2014 or 15 location Algeria
Northern Africa species titanis Gojira
size gigantic 398 ft
tall so if you like this video then
watch this one as well and if you're
more interested in other movie monsters
and creatures then check out our Channel
like subscribe and we'll see you on the
next one take care fam